you know Keri Russell has come a long  way since her days on Felicity got me  through my adolescent hello by the way  she earned her first Emmy nomination  last year for the Americans a fabulous  show in your day she got her star on the  Hollywood Walk yes indeed and we joined  Carey for the celebration it's an  incredible honor obviously longtime  partner and co-star on the Americans  Matthew Reese was there but Carey's kids  well they had other plans  my daughter Willa what I'd like to have  dressed up but they're on a very big  camping trip and director JJ Abrams  shared some sweet memories of his friend  who we first met when she was just 15  years old on the Mickey Mouse Club  I guess my wrapping on The Mickey Mouse  Club was that good you know like you end  up here  you